comment sauver les animaux de france de
l'extinction massive
excédé par les fausses promesses des
moniales macron pour l'environnement les
associations notre affaire à tous et
polynice qui protège les insectes
pollinisateurs comme les abeilles ont
choisi la voie juridique elles ont tout
d'abord déposer des injonctions en
septembre dernier pour protester contre
le manque de transparence de
l'homologation des pesticides et aux
surprises l'état n'a pas répondu dans le
délai imparti rejoints par les
associations à spa san bertos et
biodiversité sous nos pieds elles ont
déposé hier matin un recours en carence
fautive contre l'état ou tribunal
administratif de paris il vise à voir
reconnaître le préjudice écologique
vis-à-vis de la biodiversité en effet
les chiffres font froid dans le dos
depuis 2008 sur 13 1842 espèces animales
évalué 17,6 sont menacées de disparition
30 % des oiseaux ont été anéantis dans
les milieux agricoles pour les insectes
on se base sur les chiffres de
l'allemagne - 76% des insectes en
moyenne une hécatombe
l'artificialisation des sols et
l'intensification des pratiques
agricoles sont en partie responsables de
ces extinctions massives
l'utilisation accrue de pesticides
néonicotinoïdes notamment induisent des
mortalités importantes chez les insectes
néonicotinoïdes dans l'autorisation à
d'ailleurs été redonné dans certains cas
en france la directrice du plaidoyer de
polynice explique nous nous demandons au
gouvernement d'abord que l'on nous
voudrions qu'il soit reconnu comme
responsable de cet effondrement mais
nous faisons ça pour forcer les
gouvernements à agir vraiment pour
réduire l'usagé des pesticides et pour
cela nous attaquons l'état sur un point
très précis qui est l'évaluation et
l'autorisation des pesticides ce
processus là est défaillant obsolète et
il permet la mise sur le marché de deux
2 milliers de tonnes de pesticides qui
sont hautement toxiques pour
l'environnement grandes utilisatrices de
ces produits de synthèse l'hexagone
promettant en 2007 sous l'impulsion de
jean louis borloo devrait dire lusage de
50% à l'horizon 2025 et bien à la place
leur utilisation a augmenté d'au moins
15% en 10 ans le plan de réduction des
pesticides a pourtant côté un milliard
d'euros mais les initiatives ont été
contreproductives
par exemple de nouveaux dispositifs de
surveillance des insectes nuisibles et
des maladies ont été mises en place pour
réguler et diminuer l'usagé de
pesticides en réalité ces détections au
finalement poussé les agriculteurs à
utiliser davantage de produits
phytosanitaires et elles ont été
dévoyées par l'agrobusiness qui
prévenait les agriculteurs des nuisances
à venir pour qu'ils aient recours à
leurs produits mais voilà lorsque les
verts se sont mobilisés contre les
pesticides à la proche des habitations
ils ont dû s'engager dans des bras de
fer juridique sans grand succès alors
face à l'effondrement rapide de la
biodiversité les militants se battent
pour que les effets des pesticides soit
documenté et présentées au public à
l'heure où beaucoup s'inquiètent de ce
qu'on leur injecte sous la peau il
serait bon de savoir quels produits on
ingère lorsqu'on mange ou ce que l'on
respire chaque jour déjà fin 2018 la
sphère du siècle notre collectif
d'associations avaient attaqué la france
pour une action climatique
et ça a marché le 14 octobre 2021 le
tribunal administratif de paris a sommé
l'état français de réparer les dommages
causés à l'environnement et ce avant le
31 décembre 2022 un an pour changer la
donne autant dire mission impossible
la france a prévu de mettre en place 30
% d'aires protégées d'ici 2022 mais ce
n'est pas à la hauteur des pressions sur
les espèces cette fois-ci quelles que
soient les pilotes de ce recours on ne
voit pas comment la france pourrait
faire revenir les oiseaux et les
insectes d'entre les morts il n'y aura
pas de jésus au gouvernement pour
ressusciter sauterelles et chauve souris
plutôt des judas